and it went from dave thanks for all of
your advice to you know you're a
charlatan snake oil salesman because
like there's about 20 000 trolls the the
death squad guys literally they stick
them on me so all of a sudden my social
media just went all to hell overnight
like wow
this is kind of freaking me out and i
didn't really know how to take it so i
did some of the weird personal
development stuff that i do and and i
just realized after a little while every
time joe says something bad about me i'm
selling more coffee
even though like it kind of hurts
and i just realized i didn't do anything
wrong i
did everything at the highest integrity
bottom line is i'm pretty sure that
there's a reason the companies that joe
owns are starting to sell mct oil and
trying to copy the coffee they just
couldn't do the mold free thing so we
tried to say it wasn't real and i would
challenge anyone who thinks it's not
real to just read what i write
damn okay
that's spicy
joe thank you brother i appreciate all
the sales i appreciate you i appreciate
all the stuff you're doing in the world
and
i don't feel bad for not getting high
before i was interviewed on your show
because i would have sounded like a
total idiot
[Music]
this is episode 104 of the michaela
peterson podcast today i am joined by
dave asprey dave asprey is the founder
and chairman of bulletproof
and one of the world's first biohackers
probably the first not only is he a
four-time new york best-selling author
but he's helped so many people improve
their health we spoke about internal and
external factors that can impact one's
mind and body from fasting and dietary
restrictions to supplements and mold
what he went through joe rogan
we discussed sleep problems in depth and
i've actually fixed my sleep since then
turns out i was reacting to citric acid
and the electrolytes i was taking that's
been keeping me awake at night for an
entire year yeah i'll be releasing
something about that if you enjoyed this
please remember to subscribe and i
believe dave is hosting a biohacking
conference this september if you guys
are interested in going to florida
meeting a whole bunch of interesting
open individuals learning about health
i'd recommend checking that out it's
linked below i'd like to introduce you
or reintroduce you to one of my favorite
snacks brooklyn biltong available at
brooklynbiltong.com
one of the easiest ways to get healthy
is to replace the over-processed food
and snacks that are no good that you're
eating with healthy food that's still
kind of snacky if you can do it like
jerky or biltong i went cold turkey into
pure health food no packaged foods no
fun no air fryers i didn't know how to
cook i was 23. it was really not fun
and a huge part of that was because
there actually weren't any packaged
foods that were healthy enough that i
could comfortably eat with my insanely
limited autoimmune paleo diet at the
time now i'm on the lion diet and it's
even more limited
but i can still eat these guys
brooklynbiltong.com is a small company
that makes biltong which is a south
african dried meat dish and their
options are either spiced
like so
or made with just salt and apple cider
vinegar their naked version code mp gets
you 15 off these ingredients are
beautiful apple cider vinegar real salt
onion powder black pepper lemon juice
rosemary and beef
if you're snacking all the time
consider switching to something like
that it's a health food but it's still
in a bag you just switch over it's easy
brooklynbuilton.com use codemp for 15
off enjoy the episode
[Music]
dave asprey welcome to my podcast
michaela i'm super happy to be here
i'm excited to talk to you i've known
about you for years the guy behind
bulletproof coffee
yeah a few other little biohacking
things here and there uh including
i'm one of the early major grass-fed
meat voices where it's so important to
get it and watching you as you dealt
with a lot of the same stuff that i
dealt with just in your own health and
saying oh look what happens when you eat
the right meat and you get rid of bad
stuff in your gut so i'm i am
impressed and amused and just happy to
see all the changes that you've had in
your life from switching out how you eat
because it makes such a difference
it really really does i actually got
better oh it's funny i'll for the first
year in a bed i ate mainly grain fed it
wasn't grain fed like corn fed because
canada i think
has even their low quality beef seems to
be better than the low quality beef in
america but it was amazing
but yeah oh yeah right but it was mainly
grass
fed grain finished yeah but now you know
i eat the best i can afford so i eat
grass-fed because
why wouldn't you eat grass-fed if you
can buy grass-fed
you do it partly for the soil partly for
the animal and also to avoid glyphosate
because there's so much of that in
grain-fed beef and it disrupts gut
bacteria and if you're working on
healing stuff
it's one of those things where
we're kind of a reflection of the soil
that we live on and around
okay interesting we should probably get
into that
but we should start off if anyone
doesn't know who you are or isn't
familiar with your work can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what you do
sure i'm a former silicon valley
computer hacker and entrepreneur
about 10 years ago i started the field
of biohacking and the original
definition of that is the art and
science of changing the environment
around you and inside of you so that you
have control of your own biology i did
that because i weighed 300 pounds i had
brain fog chronic fatigue syndrome high
risk of stroke and heart attack
arthritis
and a bunch of other
other bad stuff going on before i was
30. so i'm financially successful you
know
at the company they held google's first
servers and
i have the accelerator pressed all the
way to the floor and i'm slowing down
and like what are you doing i'm 26 years
old and so i bought disability insurance
because i wouldn't have hired myself i
was truly afraid i ended up spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars fixing
my biology and then about more than a
million more upgrading my biology
i'm well known for bulletproof coffee
which is a venture-backed company that i
raised 80 million dollars for and i've
stepped away from that entirely i am now
ceo of upgrade labs
which is franchising this year to
hundreds of locations
around this is a facility lets you go in
and upgrade human biology
better than you could at a gym
okay that's fascinating
okay i want to know more about that
upgrade upgrade labs
yep upgradelabs.com there you go now i
just did that subtle plug did you see it
that i did yeah so where can i go to get
that upgradelabs.com okay i want to get
into that um can we start off will you
give a brief background about what
biohacking is
uh so can you give me just right off the
bat
what can the regular person do to
upgrade like top three biohacks and then
we can delve into them
well
one of the things that happens is you
get
you get something wrong with you and say
i'm gonna do what's supposed to work
which usually comes from big pharma or
big food telling you buy our stuff it'll
work they also told you smoking was good
for you so you realize that doesn't work
because you got worse that's what
happened to me and they said i'm going
to do what works and i want to spend the
least amount of time to get the most
benefit possible
the three things that are going to give
you the most benefit from biohacking is
learning how to get better quality sleep
i don't mean more sleep i mean more
sleep and less time so that your body
makes the hormones it's supposed to make
when you're asleep
learning how to intermittent fast which
was the topic of my last book and this
is just teaching your body that it's
safe normal and healthy to go for 12 to
16 hours without food without inducing a
panic response it'll make you live
longer and it'll actually make you feel
better now skipping breakfast is cheaper
than buying breakfast even if you like
egg mcmuffins or something
so you can do this it doesn't cost you
anything learning to sleep well at night
is usually changing some practices there
might be 50 or 100 bucks worth of stuff
to buy but it's not expensive
and you can always use aluminum foil to
black out your bedroom so that's 10
cents worth of foil we're talking very
cheap stuff
and then the third thing is learning
what to eat and more importantly what
not to eat and that's the subject of the
bulletproof diet which is how people
lose more than a million pounds and i
tell you there's five things
in foods that are messing with you i
call them kryptonite and funny enough
there's lectins which are plant toxins
there's ox oxalates which are plant
toxins and this is first published in
2011
there's phytic acid which blocks your
ability to absorb minerals which is also
a plant toxin there's mycotoxins which
come from fungus that eats plants and
also accumulates in animals and so four
of these major toxins
are coming from plants and what's the
fifth one
oh omega-6 fatty acids the inflammatory
seed oils so these are all
i'm saying don't do the stuff that harms
you stop that and then you can do
something that makes you feel better so
i'm going to boil all that down to
replace all of your seed oils with
grass-fed butter because grass-fed
butter is three dollars a pound
and if you just did that
you're gonna win
okay that's handy you said something
about phytic acid
yes okay what is that
ladic acid is commonly found in
nuts but most commonly in grains and
things like beans
and it is there to keep animals from
eating the plant because plants don't
want us to eat them they don't want to
eat their babies they can't run away
because they have roots so they either
develop hard shells or spikes or usually
chemicals so if you were to go out in
the forest and just eat some plants
you'll probably end up in the hospital
if you make it that far most plants will
kill you right away the ones that we
consider edible it means you won't die
right away if you eat them during a
famine
and what we have to do is choose the low
inflammation plants that you can eat
over time what phytic acid does is it
sticks to things like zinc
that are necessary for your body and
they prevent your body from absorbing it
so if you're one of those raw vegans
like i used to be or when i stopped
being a raw vegan a normal vegan
what actually normal vegan is that a
thing anyway um i went and i said okay
what's going on here well you get
mineral deficient because all of the
minerals that you eat from your plant
proteins are not absorbable because
they're always coming with phytic acid
so for every pound of plant protein you
need a pound of meat protein to overcome
the phytic acid that prevents you from
getting the minerals like zinc that are
good for protecting you from covid hmm
okay that's very interesting so do you
think part of the reason that there are
so many people who are zinc deficient is
because they're eating plants or or
anything that's too high in phytic acid
phytic acid is a major cause but frankly
glyphosate is probably a bigger cause
glyphosate or roundup as it's known is
this amazing
herbicide that destroys soil and we have
this habit of spraying it now on
garbanzo beans and wheat on most grains
before we harvest them because it makes
them dry up more quickly at the end of
the season
so especially in the u.s the average
person now is getting about a pound a
year of this
of this weed killer that affects your
gut bacteria and it unfortunately also
is a chelator of zinc so i think that's
why it's a combination of phytic acid if
you're going to eat a lot of plants and
the plants we double down by spraying
them with something that hurts our gut
bacteria
okay that's lovely
did you suffer from lyme
disease well
yes well at least i had lyme disease
whether i was suffering from it is
questionable about 90 of people who have
lyme disease
actually have toxic mold so what i had
was i had
provable toxic mold exposure and
symptoms of that and i had started a lab
testing company along with my wife who's
a medical doctor and we proved that i
had an active lyme disease infection but
since mold toxins and lyme toxins are
almost identical chemically
almost everyone who says i have lyme
disease if we run the labs you're going
to find out you actually have toxic malt
so i always tell people treat the mold
first i've done a documentary it's free
moldymovie.com talking about that anyone
with lime who sees that would be like oh
my god that's me oh and i have black
stains on my ceiling and i think i have
lyme disease so you really have to just
discern between the two there are some
people who have lyme
but if you and i walked down the street
and gathered pea from 100 people 95 of
them are going to have lyme spirit dna
in their urine they don't have lyme
disease though it's because their immune
system works so the mold takes out the
immune system then the lyme takes over
so it's a very complex disease and i
don't want to say there isn't such thing
as lime there is it just always travels
with mold when you treat the mold the
body can resolve the lime unless you
have co-infections which i also had
okay
what kind of tests do you do to test for
mold
or mold toxicity well
you can do
a test there's a company called my
mycolab that will test for
an immune response to mold toxins
and they'll be able to show you do you
have an active mold infection in the
body or are you getting exposed in your
environment
which is probably the most
the most
advanced test you can get now you can
also get a urine test to see am i peeing
out mycotoxins which all of us do
because food always has some amount and
what i've found and there are dozens
actually hundreds of studies supporting
this is when you lower the burden of
mold in your food and in your
environment your body works better and
that's that's one of the practices in my
recommendations is like let's
not have
mold standards in the u.s that either
don't exist or are five or ten times
higher than european standards so when
food or certain beverages get rejected
from many countries they send them to
the us and canada and then we eat them
because our standards are not very good
like seriously china will reject coffee
and we'll drink it
that's exactly what i want to hear
okay that's that's really interesting i
grew up when i left home we found out
there's black mold in our basement like
all over the basement
uh which was pretty brutal uh yeah not
good my brother slept in that basement i
slept in the basement too
yeah so that's something that both of us
have as like that's what lit the fuse
for us
okay
okay but then say you remove that you
know like um i've moved around i'm in a
condo building right not right now but
usually i live in a condo building it's
fairly new there's no mold there
theoretically if you remove that kind of
thing from your environment do you have
to
recover somehow or can you just kind of
wait your body normalizes if you're not
in a toxic environment
it depends in part on your genetics
it depends in part on how long you were
there and it also depends on whether the
mold took up residence in the body which
it can do
there are certain people and northern
europeans tend to have more of this but
not always
and
we are the ones who are wired to survive
uh famines and the ones who are wired to
be able to go steal from the neighboring
tribe
so
we have
the genetics that allow us to have blood
that clots quickly and we recycle our
fatty acids better than the average
human i am one of these it's called hla
dr4 is the genetic subtype okay and this
is great because it means that okay i'm
in europe and we're gonna like roll
across the czech republic or something
and let's just go to this village we
don't know anyone like kill a few people
steal a few bags of food take an arrow
hit maybe not bleed to death not die of
whatever current plague is here and then
live to fight another day so you do that
for a few thousand years you get the
genes to be basically like a bandit
well
this is good because if there's no food
for well you're gonna you're gonna
survive unfortunately mold and lyme
toxins recirculate in your bile
and
we are genetically wired to conserve
bile so that we can live through famines
better than people have to eat more
well
pros and cons in today's environment
since those toxins are fat-soluble we
just keep recycling those toxins and it
can take a very long time to get rid of
those if you've been exposed and you're
not actively detoxing
as i've written in some of my books it
takes a little bit more than two years
to replace half the fat and your cell
membranes so imagine if you put a drop
of
food coloring
like in it in a bottle of water like it
slowly percolates through but then you
have to like pour in more water to
dilute it out well that's how those mold
toxins are once they've percolated into
the lining of your nerves into your
brain into your
every cell in your body every
mitochondrial membrane is made of fat so
now it's like you've been dyed light
blue and you have to wash those through
with the higher fat diet increasing bile
turnover and using toxin binders if you
don't do that you'll probably be one of
those highly sensitive people possibly
for 10 or 20 years
the other thing that mold will do
in the environment there's always this
amazing interplay this goes back to the
definition of biohacking it changed the
environment around you and inside of you
so if molds out here mold makes
antibiotics by definition we are biotics
we are powered by bacterias mold and
bacteria ancient enemies
now
the mold will talk to the bacteria in
your sinuses and
the bacteria there says i'm under threat
let me make a biofilm and let me start
creating things that cause brain fog so
now even if you leave the mold you have
this kind of slimy infection in the back
of your sinuses right up against your
brain that's making a toxin that makes
you have brain fog i dealt with this
profound brain fog that made me feel
stupid to be honest i'm in business
school at wharton and i'm failing like
what is going on
so you really do want to bind the toxins
and you can heal from all this but it
takes time and you've got to calm the
immune system and then heal the nervous
system heal the lining of the nerves and
i will tell you i am much higher
functioning cognitively than i've ever
been in my entire life energetically the
whole thing and it's because i got rid
of those toxins
okay that's very interesting so
the g the dna that makes people into
bandits you mentioned hla does that
cover all the hlas like the one that
predisposes you to ankylosing
spondylitis and celiac disease this is
just hla and
all of them well the hla dr4 are the
subtypes that make you more sensitive to
mold and okay
and lime but many of the other hla hl's
like a big part of your dna yeah frankly
there's people who are probably better
qualified to answer that one than i am
i'm not a geneticist but i know enough
to be dangerous on the genetics brand
fair fair enough that's very interesting
this episode is also brought to you by
grass-fed beef organs
by ancestral supplements ancestral
supplements makes new zealand source
nose-to-tail organ meats bone marrow and
beef organs in simple convenient gelatin
capsules like so
traditional peoples native americans and
early ancestral healers believed that
eating the organs from a healthy animal
would strengthen and support the health
of the corresponding organ of the
individual
for instance the traditional way of
treating a person with a weak heart was
to feed the person the heart of a
healthy animal
similarly eating the kidneys of a
healthy animal was believed to support
urinary ailments and overall kidney
health pancreas was fed to people with
digestive problems and spleen was fed to
people with immune and blood
deficiencies but now you don't have to
do that you can just take these
our early ancestors knew this which is
why their traditional diets included the
frequent and nourishing consumption of
nose-to-tail organs visit
ancestralsupplements.com to see what
they can do for you
ancestral supplements putting back in
the modern world has left out
enjoy the rest of the episode
okay
let's let's cover this before we delve
into more i had a number of people in my
audience ask about joe rogan because
apparently there's something going on
with you and joe rogan so can you give a
bit of a background about
what that's about and what happened sure
something like seven years ago
i went on the joe rogan show uh three
times
and
uh in fact i'll post something on
instagram because you can't see it joe
pulled it off of spotify he's been
trying to hide this
and
uh bulletproof coffee changes brain for
the better i mean he's worn the
bulletproof t-shirt on on there and was
just a huge fan and i uh and he's like
oh my goodness grass-fed beef this is so
important i i love all this
but then one of his buddies decided to
try to steal
both the name bulletproof as well as uh
my ideas and one of the companies he
owns decided to try to steal and copy my
products and the day they made that
decision he made up some stuff around uh
around me
as well as uh some fake tests that have
never existed as far as i can tell
saying that my coffee was moldy guys
i've spent way more than a hundred
thousand dollars on lab tests over the
years the bulletproof coffee that i
created is lab tested to the highest
possible standards
um but he basically tried to discredit
me
for quite a while it looks like it was
partly financially motivated and partly
probably one of his buddies manipulating
him
and so i i learned a lot
about bullying and what bullies do when
they grow up
it was it was rough because i'm like i'm
helping people i'm i'm motivated by not
letting people get to 300 pounds like i
did and just not have brain fog and i
know the kind of suffering out there and
it went from dave thanks for all of your
advice to you know you're a charlatan
snake oil salesman because like there's
about 20 000 trolls the the death squad
guys
and literally they stick them on me so
all of a sudden my social media just
went all to hell overnight like wow
this is kind of freaking me out and i
didn't really know how to take it so i
did some of the weird personal
development stuff that i do and i just
realized after a little while every time
joe says something bad about me i'm
selling more coffee
even though like it kind of hurts
and i just realized i didn't do anything
wrong i
did everything at the highest integrity
uh and what's cool is
uh now that joe's pulled those things
down there's fair use exemptions so i
put together a compilation of all the
things joe said and like you can try and
reel it back by deleting it but
bottom line is i'm pretty sure that
there's a reason the companies that joe
owns are starting to sell mct oil and
trying to copy the coffee they just
couldn't do the mold free thing so we
tried to say it wasn't real and i would
challenge anyone who thinks it's not
real to just read what i write
damn okay
that's spicy
joe thank you brother i appreciate all
the sales i appreciate you i appreciate
all the stuff you're doing in the world
and uh i don't feel bad for not getting
high before i was interviewed on your
show because i just sounded like a total
idiot
okay
at the beginning of this this is
something i actually really need help
with at the beginning of this episode
you mentioned sleep and how important
that is and when i first kind of started
my
health journey
i didn't recognize how important sleep
was because i was constantly
like totally [ __ ] up so i just didn't
know that sleeping didn't make me feel
any better because i was so sick that
i just didn't recognize how important it
is and now particularly and i've seen
this across people who go to the zero
carb diet this doesn't happen for
everybody and i've seen a lot of people
improve their sleep but for me i'm at
the moment i'm kind of stuck on this
because if i have any type of plan i get
arthritis eventually i haven't figured
out how to get past that
but i have noticed that my sleep isn't
as good as it should be
and oh this is so good
yeah it improved like i i mean i'm way
healthier than i was
um
and i've been under a lot of stress with
family health and so it's hard to say
how much of that is playing into my
sleep because i whenever i get stressed
i don't sleep as well but i have seen
some people who go zero carb have a
harder time staying asleep throughout
the night so
what are some tricks people can use
whether or not there's zero carb
to improve their sleep quality
back when i was developing the
bulletproof diet before i wrote the book
i went through a three month period of i
can't quite claim zero carbs i had one
serving of broccoli every day that was
the entire extent of my cravings so it's
about as close to zero as you can get
right yeah
and i experienced the same thing that
happens i call it the keto trap and
there's a similar one i call the fasting
trap in my latest book and it's that if
something is good more of it is better
it's like it's just a human behavioral
thing that we do right
so when it comes to the zero carb thing
you feel freaking amazing for the first
month or so right like
the the curtains have lifted your brain
works your joints don't hurt i was
diagnosed with arthritis when i was 14.
so
same thing many many plants do that for
me
uh and i know the ones that don't and
those are the ones that generally don't
do it for most people
and when uh when you get that right you
feel uh you feel so good so you say i'm
gonna do it even more
and there is something that hits women
before men
for women it's usually two to four weeks
before men and it's always in this order
if you're over fasting or you're over
ketoing i'm gonna call it
and step one is a reduction in sleep
quality no matter how much you sleep you
wake up and you feel like you didn't
really sleep i've been tracking my sleep
for 15 years so when i did this
experiment i used to wear a headband at
night to track my sleep and what i found
was after three months of this i was
waking up 12 times per night without
knowing it and i was getting five
minutes of deep sleep at night
okay okay but i didn't know it you won't
detect this yeah yeah so usually with
women four to six weeks of zero carbon
sometimes even less
um they're just like i'd wake up and i
feel like i didn't sleep and then the
second thing is oh my monthly cycle
isn't as regular as it should be and the
third thing is my hair gets thinner
right with guys give us an extra couple
weeks first sleep quality goes down
then the second thing is i wake up
without a kickstand and the third thing
is my hair gets thinner
so how do you fix it what's going on
here well here's what's going on with
you michaela
when the body is at rest there's two
kinds of cells in the brain two big
categories and the neurons which are the
rock stars of the brain
they totally like ketones and they're
super happy to have ketones and if they
have a choice of glucose or ketones they
will choose ketones because they need
the energy
well the maintenance crew the janitors
the immune cells that control
inflammation in the brain they want
carbs more than ketones
and this is why the bulletproof diet is
cyclical going in and out of ketosis but
it's never a high carb diet
and it's not a high sugar diet and the
type of fat matters and all that but
what's happening with you is your body
says hmm
at night i need to be pumping
this glymphatic system in and out the
glymphatic system is something that
inside the brain the cells when you
sleep properly they dump a lot of water
that contains some
inflammatory proteins that happen during
the day and then they're supposed to get
flushed out and then it's refilled with
clean cerebral spinal fluid yeah well
in order to do that you got to have
enough mitochondrial energy and the body
says i don't have enough glucose to do
this
so how do i get glucose oh easy how
about some adrenaline and cortisol which
are the two hormones that make
the easiest and fastest access to
glucose in other words the brain says
low energy emergency and it does this
between three and four in the morning is
my guess right
is that the time when you're most likely
to wake up that's when it is for most
people
probably
um i don't know i haven't really woken
up
uh i don't know i don't have a ring it's
possible i use an aura ring yeah okay
yeah i mean too
so that'll usually tell you about the
time but some it can be between two and
five but it's usually around three or
four is when the peak is and what that
is is just the body saying i needed some
carbs it didn't need a lot of carbs it
just needed a little bit
so here's a tip that i have been writing
about forever and it's one thing that
it drives everyone nuts because it
shouldn't work but it does and it's raw
honey
okay i've seen a small amount
i i've been doing that i've been doing
that i've been doing that before bed
because i thought
maybe it would help
it does for some people but not everyone
yeah
no it hasn't and i wasn't like i mean i
can eat honey now i at the beginning i
couldn't eat honey it would make me feel
weird now i can eat honey i can drink
tea i'm less sensitive than i was
um i will talk about plants next but
no
so which is why i thought maybe it was
stress too
well it is stress because adrenaline and
cortisol are stressed but what will
happen is you'll think it's stress
because the body biologically asks for
stress hormones to get you some sugar
and then when the stress hormones kick
in you're going to what am i stressed
about and whatever is top of mind you'll
have ruminating speeding thoughts in the
middle of the night so you can't go back
to sleep because you're stressing about
stuff but you're not stressing because
of the stuff you're stressing because of
biology which made you think about the
stuff
it's kind of a chicken and egg thing i
definitely have stuff to stress about it
might be horrible
it might be i've been following
how much how much um
like how much how many carbs how much
carb would somebody need theoretically
to give their body
the glucose that they would potentially
need to not have this cortisol spike
it totally depends on the size of the
body and the type of carb the reason raw
honey is kind of magic is raw honey
preferentially goes to liver glycogen
and glycogen is how we store
carbohydrates in our body
liver glycogen will feed the brain and
muscle glycogen will feed the rest of
the body so if you only have a little
bit of raw honey it'll go to the liver
and then the liver will have it ready
for the brain when you need it so it's
uh it's preferential to do it that way
but if you put raw honey in hot tea it's
not raw anymore so it's usually i say
start with one teaspoon and go up to
maybe four teaspoons before bed and that
can be life-changing
it's not that much and why does it have
to be raw
well the study that i found i think that
one's in the bulletproof diet book the
study that i found showed that the raw
honey is the stuff that goes to liver
glycogen but when you pasteurize the
honey it just acts like normal sugar in
the body so it goes to muscle glycogen
and since liver glycogen is more
available for the brain and we're trying
to make the brain do it and still allow
you to be in ketosis because you if you
have less than 15 grams and maybe you
have some mct oil with that honey you
ought to be able to hang in there with
ketosis or you cycle in and out you're
in ketosis for three four days and then
you cycle out
but if the raw honey trick doesn't work
and i've written like a dozen plus
articles on sleep hacking and i have a
challenge for it
because it's been such a problem for me
and now i get like two hours of deep and
an hour and a half of rim and six hours
on a regular size beautiful it's
life-changing but i did not have this
five years ago i've worked really hard
on it but the other thing collagen
protein because i'm like the guy made
mct oil and collagen cool collagen
protein from grass-fed cows so you don't
get the the glyphosate that would get in
there otherwise
that stuff
makes a huge difference for another
group of people because of glycine
and glycine is the dominant amino acid
glycine is the third most common detox
pathway so you're dealing with mold and
so the number one detox pathway is
glutathione you can get that as a
supplement number two is glucorate
calcium diglucrate that's a supplement
number three is glycine so if you look
at all the mold toxins that you've been
exposed to that's the order of
operations for most of them
so
that
that collagen protein that we talk about
for nice hair and skin and all
well it is a detox protein but it also
has
electrical chemical
it also has the electrical properties as
a chemical in the body in that it drives
the fascia and mold interrupts
electricity flow in the body because it
reduces mitochondrial membrane potential
which is
super technical stuff
but the bottom line is when you have
healthier connective planes it can lower
stress in the body
you'll also find that people call
collagen animal carbohydrate or animal
starch
and
there is a study that shows that
collagen can be broken down by bacteria
in the gut into butyric acid so for
people like you have a really hard time
with any plant including something like
acacia gum which is usually a soluble
fiber most people handle very well that
could feed good good gut bacteria to
make more butyric acid collagen may work
for you so collagen before sleep just
maybe one scoop of it would be a really
good idea and there's lots of good
brands of collagen just make sure it's
grass-fed out there
okay i'm gonna try that before i release
this episode and see if that makes a
difference i have not tried
collagen to see if that would make a
difference
so if you wanted to just go all in
try grass-fed honey mixed in room
temperature water
with
so you got honey collagen and a little
bit of mct oil and then you've hit all
three of the pathways you'll have enough
keto energy because you'll get some beta
hydroxybutyrate which comes out of the
mcts you have some collagen
right and then you have the raw honey
and if you sleep like a baby then you
know and if that still doesn't work
here's what happened the mold made the
mast cells in your body um overactive
mast cells are your immune cells and
they're kind of like firewalls and
imagine if you you have those alerts on
your phone right and it's like bing bing
bing all the time well if your immune
system is getting bing bing binged all
the time
well maybe you could turn that down and
this will sound totally crazy but try a
benadryl before you go to bed and if
that changes your life well there you go
you have allergies
yeah yeah well um that's what i have
used before
not ben benadryl but the same kind of
thing drama meme
it's like it it's gravel it's basically
slightly different but there's i know
there's overlap
uh so that works if i'm super stressed
out like something bad happens and then
i get nightmares or something
a lot of mold people if you use claritin
and pepsidase that can work really well
so i hate claritin claritin gives me
like this horrible crawling sensation
and lower back pain and things i avoid
claritin
yeah
so that means you have some sort of
histamine issue going on as well which
is underlying your mold to cause the
histamine issue but it gets more complex
when you get into histamine so and this
is why with biopsy i definitely have a
histamine issue i mean i've got many
issues but there's definitely a
histamine issue there if i eat anything
aged like i can't do aged meat at all
i can't either that stuff is so not good
for you
okay it's not like who came up with the
idea that moldy meat tasted better than
not moldy meat it was like do you want
it to be 120 days old no
who told you that tastes better
you know who told you that the guys who
didn't have refrigerators in the 1800s
and it was the only way we could
preserve meat uh no
on my farm we have about 25 pigs 25
sheep we we go to the ethical butcher
here like no hang the meat for three
days don't hang it for 10 days and then
freeze it and magically everyone feels
good when they eat it and it still
tastes great but we have this belief
that if you age meat somehow it's going
to be
better for you but what it does is you
can waste a third of the meat in
moisture loss and then having to cut off
all the black parts where stuff is
growing like why do you want to eat hold
on a fungus that eats meat if you're
going to eat that
cook it rare and you're going to put
that fungus in your body yeah that
doesn't seem smart to me that seems
not good it doesn't seem smart at all no
i was in i was less people get tired and
want dessert after they eat aged meat
they don't know why it's because of that
response histamine makes you
crave sugar
oh that's interesting i know a lot of
people like none oh i do have a lot
going on but i know a lot of people too
who are like oh i can't eat beef even if
it's grass-fed beef i can't eat beef
because it upsets my stomach i'm like
how how old is the meat you're eating is
have you only eaten aged steaks because
it could be that how old and how burned
those are the two big things and
honestly take a quarter of a benadryl
when you eat a piece of age steak and
magically you feel perfectly normal
afterwards and otherwise you feel super
tired oh that's weird
oh i'm gonna test that out that's fun
just take an antihistamine and see what
happens yeah cool it'll totally change
your ability to go to a restaurant and
eat something that you want to eat and i
love it because living in a moldy
basement like there's some predictable
stuff that happens the whole lime versus
mold thing where they're both real but
the mold caused the lime i don't live
through all that hacked all that stuff
and
where you are now you have like five
more levels of performance above where
you are and you're going to get to the
point like i have this resilience that i
don't even believe is possible
i just know how to do it and it
shouldn't have cost me a million bucks
i'm just lucky i got to do that
that's interesting okay okay so the next
question so i'm in this i'm just going
to use this to like
solve my health problems but the next
problem is so i've been on an all meat
diet
all my arthritic symptoms are gone my
mood is good
i'm pretty happy my digestion is good
but
i was hoping that at some point i would
be able to introduce
plants back in and vary my diet i'm not
one of those
carnivore people that's like i want to
do this forever if i have to do it
forever i'm happy i don't have arthritis
but that's not the goal right the goal
is to get some resiliency back which is
what you were talking about so i've
tried i can't tolerate any probiotics
like not at all i get arthritis
when i take them i've tried a number of
different types
so i don't really know where to start
i've tried incorporating plants back in
and i've eventually dropped them because
i'll get arthritis my skin will break
out i'll get bloated
uh even if it's like very small amounts
and they're cooked or pressure cooked
like i'm
trying a bunch of different things
so i try to
first i tried organic
first i tried organic apples with no
skin
pressure cooked like baby food
um and that
like i'm more resilient than i was but
it was still eventually i ended up
getting arthritis i tried pressure
cooked blueberries organic blueberries
that didn't work out so then
about
six months later i was like well maybe
i'll try greens and i know a lot of
people have
things against greens but lettuce was
one of the things i tolerated really
well that didn't suggest you start with
lettuce
did not cause arthritis no it didn't for
a really long time like when i first
went low carb i was eating a lot of
different vegetables and i didn't have
arthritis and then
things changed and i started getting
arthritis from them but i couldn't do
lettuce either it got bloated i got
tired just passed out afterwards
uh
and then the next morning i was like
puffy and eventually the arthritis came
back and i was like [ __ ] it i'll just
wait and see if something changes but
you know do you ever take betaine hcl
the stomach acid with your veggies i
tried i didn't try betaine when i
reintroduced them i tried betaine before
but it
even at the low dose i could kind of
feel burning and was like i think that's
a sign that i don't need extra stomach
acid
so i didn't continue it it might be
worth trying with the veggies or taking
a really strong digestive enzyme without
contains pepsin
okay a really good thing for you they
make
plant-based digestive enzymes a lot of
which come from fermentation and they
make animal-based ones which come from
usually from pork
the animal-based digestive enzymes are
going to be the ones to work with for
you even if you're eating plants just
because they'll be more familiar to your
system
and lettuce is something that most
people handle pretty well
and like i said you handled it for a
while so you may need to vary a little
bit more on a typical
rotation diet you eat something from a
family of foods only once every four
days when you're getting
tied into it
also
if you
look on on my show i have an episode
with a stanford researcher who wrote the
end of food allergy
where she talks about introducing very
tiny amounts of food back in
and what i suspect is going on
with you and what i've i've seen in so
many
people there's
there are these five things i talk about
in vegetables that that can cause
problems there's oxalic acid and there's
lectins well your body makes a thousand
different types of lectin every day this
is a very common type of
biochemical that just means these are
proteins that stick to sugars it's not
that big of a deal
and then in the plant kingdom there are
many many different types of lectins
and i would say here's the big problem
lectins but when people go all out
saying i'm never going to eat any lectin
again i've seen people get more
sensitive than they were before so what
you want to do is for brief periods
figure out which ones are the problems
and newsflash grains and nightshades
are the issue for almost everyone on
beans and legumes foreign
but after that like do you really have
to worry about like
lettuce squash
uh well lettuce shouldn't have any
lectins but you have to worry about
squash probably not so like you get rid
of the big ones and most people are just
fine like i don't worry about say
cashews for the vast majority of people
are fine on them but some people can't
handle those but almonds are worse than
cashews for most people so like you you
kind of pick whatever you're gonna do
that works for you but if you eliminate
everything it can take a while like a
year or two of very tiny introductions
to get it back in and the question is do
you really want to get it back in so i
would say
carrots
maybe celery most people handle celery
fennel
and if you have a specific problem with
nitrites that's different but generally
um
those are pretty good and if you didn't
just those you'll probably end up
handling cucumbers too
avocado you can get two if you want they
have some omega-6 but not too much and
all of them have dangerous compounds all
of them also have polyphenols that can
be really beneficial for you and a
little bit of bulk
you also might consider
the prebiotic fiber itself and it will
cause bloating at first as as you just
kind of take the hits
like you most probiotics even something
like a kombucha would just knock me on
my ass for a couple days
and
have you ever been tested for candida or
yeast in the gut
yeah i don't have it anymore but i did
when i first started dieting it went
away when i went super super low carb
but i had it badly before i knew that i
didn't it was bad
yeah
so that can be a factor that makes it
more complex but you're probably going
to want to get some either acacia gum
fiber
you can get large arabino galactin it's
called but these are plant fibers
without all the other bad stuff in the
plants so most people tolerate those and
just a tiny bit of that
with a probiotic and when you said you
can't tolerate probiotics what that what
that means is you haven't found the
probiotic that works for you i could put
on 10 pounds on the wrong probiotics
when i was really sick and it's because
your gut bacteria are highly disrupted i
take 60 grams of prebiotic fiber a day
because that's what people live the
longest do but i don't eat that many
plants and i don't need a variety of
colors and all that stuff no i eat the
ones that i know are compatible with me
and i don't overdo it
and it works very well but you you end
up getting there by figuring out what
works i'll tell you kale is not good for
most people even if they say it is and
like that's just you know that is a fact
um and i always take a lot of heat from
the kale people but know that the kale
people actually we talked it's funny
somewhere around like the early three
hundred episodes on darwin i warned him
and his followers about kale
and then it took him to many just this
last year he found like i had to quit
drinking kale smoothies because of the
oxalic acid i'm like dude seven years
ago i told you about that brother
so
kale is becoming known but raw spinach
is just as bad
so you get these spinach and kale raw
vegan stuff it shreds the gut it pokes
holes in it and you don't want to be
michaela you don't want to be dealing
with with that kind of stuff
because you have other things you're
working on like you're building your
show and you want your body to work very
well so i would say when it's going to
be a weekend when you have a little bit
of downtime try probably the spore based
probiotics i tried
i tried sporebase and i tried like
i didn't try it with a prebiotic fiber
but i was still like tiny tiny amounts
and my body was still like [ __ ] you
michaela after about five days
you know what do that with
antihistamines i bet you'll work through
it you're going to have to probably take
some hits
the immune system kinda just like calm
down everything's fine
yeah um are you taking
charcoal and bentonite clay and all the
binders because that's a big thing
especially
i took that before i'm not taking them
now like after about a year of the
carnivore diet i was like i don't have
symptoms unless i eat something wrong
and i stopped like it took about a year
before i
felt really good the entire time i was
losing weight on carnivore
i'd have like up and down icky feelings
and i figured it was just me getting rid
of whatever my fat was storing like i
wasn't really sure what was going on but
yeah
a carnivore diet or anything that makes
you lose weight like that
will cause you to burn fat and your fat
stores pesticides and heavy metals yeah
yeah yeah that's what i feel i have an
older post called the rapid fat loss
protocol and it the subtitles how to
lose weight faster than you should
because people who go on that protocol
they get brain fog unless they're
amplifying the detox pathways at the
same time
and so one guy lost 75 pounds in 75 days
i was working with which is ridiculous
but he had a lot of weight to lose right
so
what's happening when anyone goes
carnivore and starts losing weight is
okay there's a shift in your gut
bacteria that may be beneficial but
probably isn't and we're not quite sure
i there sure are lots of studies that
say you should have some soluble fiber
there are more questionable studies
about bulk fiber
and i'm much less of a fan of that the
the insoluble fiber
but if your gut won't handle it fine do
whatever it takes you know go carnivore
for a month or a year
but then what do you do
and if your gut bacteria is going to
have to shift again it normally would
shift seasonally anyway right so in
summer we would eat more vegetables and
even fruit
right and then in winter we're like okay
unless you have some potatoes in a
cellar or something you know there's
some fall carbs you get but then winter
it's keto it's carnivore
and i i think that
in fact not i don't just think i have
seen the studies that show that there's
a change in your gut composition
seasonally so you may actually say all
right it's summer now so if it's summer
maybe you won't do a few more veggies
and then go back more carnivore in
winter and see if that helps you because
i do know that you're going to get to a
point where
you can eat
food that's compatible with you that's
healthy and it won't look like what most
people eat but that's because most
people eat food that really isn't good
for them and they pay greatly for it
later i also know that if you never eat
a carb again the odds of you living as
long and as fully as you can they go
down but you might be unique or it's
right for you but most people
eventually do kind of what
my friend
paul saladino
did where he's like you know what i'm
doing really really well in carnivore
but i'm going to add in honey and maybe
a few low inflammation veggies and you
find what works for you right and you
may be an 80 fat person or 50 fat it's
okay to be variable and this is
something that you see rigidity in the
extreme keto people you see it in
carnivore you see it in vegan you see it
in fasting and michaela you are not an
average person neither am i neither is
anyone listening to this we're all
unique so you start in the middle of
average and then you move in one
direction or the other so if only
lettuce works for you fine and
if something else works that's fine too
but as long as it works but if you're
still struggling and you're so limited
and you're you know constantly breaking
out or something you just haven't solved
it yet and you got to keep pushing
that is the plan
that's the plan i'm not too super rigid
in any idea and i do think that the goal
of carnivore is
it can help a lot of people who have so
many factors and they can't figure out
what's going on limit those factors get
to a baseline level and then figure out
how to reintroduce like i think that
that should be the goal of most people
and get some resiliency back
you shouldn't be stuck if you i figure
if you're stuck in one space like if i
can only eat
you know like most of what i eat is like
lamb or beef if that's all i can eat and
i can't eat anything out else without
getting arthritis then there's still
something wrong
obviously
yeah there there is something wrong if
you can't eat something besides those
without getting arthritis
and it's it's funny because
in the the bulletproof diet has a
three-week plan where you don't eat
anything that's not in the green zone
and it's grass-fed meat and a very
limited number of veggies and a limited
number of fats and like do that for
three weeks and that's enough for the
vast majority of people who didn't have
mold exposures and whatever genetics
that we have and all that they go oh
this is how i'm capable of feeling what
else can i add back in from this list of
foods
but for you more foods are guilty and
for me than for most people and like
those foods just aren't ever going to
work right i don't think i'm ever going
to enjoy a kale salad and not feel like
crap the next day right and that's okay
so
you're going to get that dialed in but
right now there's some resilience that's
missing nutritionally
and you will get to the point where you
tolerate probiotics but if you'd asked
me you know seven eight years ago
almost all probiotics would just make me
feel like crap right anything possibly
fermented
if you go through the types that you're
taking many probiotics make histamine in
the gut but there are probiotics that
make antihistamines that you can buy as
well so you need to go out and
unfortunately spend a thousand dollars
on different brands of probiotics
and then take this one
and be like oh that sucked
wait a few days and take that one and
you're gonna find one and go oh my god
that one worked
it's just it's the trial and error sucks
on that i wish i could give you better
advice
or do that at all
here's one for you
biome
has a they'll test your poop and then
they make a custom probiotic
specifically designed for your poop that
would be interesting for you to try
v i o so i know i know viome that sounds
so unbelievable how do they have enough
data like i know most of your microbiome
you can't even plate so how can they
take that data and then make a probiotic
for you that sounds like marketing
that's real
um so i was one of the first advisors so
yes financial disclosure whatever but i
literally since the very early days the
reason they can do it is all of their
tech came from the bio warfare uh rapid
bio weapon detection stuff so they took
two billion dollars worth of los alamos
national labs ip and they're using that
and now they have a quarter million poop
samples
which means wow they've added 10 000 new
species to the database of what actually
lives in our gut that we didn't know
about and they've run machine learning
and all on it they didn't do custom
probiotics until probably like five or
six months ago
and okay i'm pretty dialed in on what i
do now right when i tried mine i noticed
the difference like the first day i was
like wow it does feel kind of different
but i noticed just like more leanness
for it so i i gotta say for you given
that you're gonna kind of be throwing
darts
they're gonna at least get you on the on
the dartboard
okay
that's really cool i'm gonna look into
that
okay how about this this is a fun
question what are some biohacks or a
biohack that you were wrong about that
you tested out on yourself
well
i was raw vegan
i was like raw vegan because enzymes and
so i had blenders and choppers and
juicers and
all kinds of stuff giant salad bowls to
try and get enough calories in
and i fell into that trap as a vegan
trap where oh i'm cold all the time my
thyroid is not working very well i'm
cracking my teeth i have
incredible joint pain upper back pain
autoimmune issues brain fog i'm tired
all the time maybe it's because i'm not
vegan enough
you know maybe i can be even more raw
maybe this you know tomato
raw tomato pasta thing i'm making with
stuff maybe i'll eat more of that of
course the tomatoes are full of
nightshade lectins right
so that was a serious mistake that
actually probably caused some harm it
took me a long time to fix
i also did the other thing where when i
was testing out the the bulletproof diet
and i said all right how far can i go
and i
i did the three months of
zero carbs other than that one serving
of broccoli a day and i was also i would
say over feeding by design i was trying
to prove look i'm only going to gain a
couple of pounds but we can eat enough
food to gain 20 pounds
but
i don't think that was good for me
because i gave myself a leaky gut and it
gave me an egg allergy and eggs are
actually especially yolks are really
good for you i didn't have an egg
allergy before i did that so leaky gut
can come about from that i should have
protected the lining of my gut better
than i did because i just didn't quite
know some of the details but that's why
i'm also a guinea pig before i publish
stuff like i'm gonna try that out
um so i that's why i recommend a
cyclical keto diet where you know you
can go really deep for a little while
but then you pop out for a bit to let
the brain recover and then you go back
in and that seems to be something that
works for a long time
um other biohacks that have not gone
well
well one time
very early in the days of
neurofeedback about
25 30 years ago
uh i bought is that right
something like that
i bought my first neurofeedback machine
and this is when people mostly didn't
know what it was unless you're a
neuroscientist
and
i had seen some effects by doing it at a
doctor's office so i said i'll do it on
myself well doing
brain surgery on yourself is probably
not a good idea
right so i i learned after being in a
few weird days where one eye is bigger
than the other maybe i should you know
have a little bit more help on that and
i ended up starting in 40 years of zen
which is doing very well it's my
neuroscience company where we do brain
upgrades like five day intense ones
but being a hacker sometimes like i have
the gear i'm just going to do it by
myself
so a couple years ago i put on one of
our 24 channel caps we called the spider
cap but i didn't really bother to adjust
the electrodes right so one of them
wasn't touching and i did some heavy
duty training
it's sort of like if you were to go to
the gym and you're doing like full power
on the right bicep but only half power
and the left bicep at the same time but
i did that to my frontal cortex and oh
my god i was such a zombie for three or
four days i was like what is wrong with
me i can't like i can't switch states
and it was it was like being
addled all the time so i called up our
in-house neuroscientist i'm like dude i
think i screwed something up and we
looked at this at the data and he's like
dave come on so we undid it and i over
overweighted the left bicep cognitively
and we fixed it but if i hadn't had
a neuroscientist there i would have just
walked around for months being kind of
an idiot
so
i just say be careful with your brain
be careful with your brain i think
that's good
okay what else
are there any supplements you suggest
most people take
you know if you're not taking vitamin d
and vitamin k
and vitamin a
you're probably doing it wrong there's
almost no one who gets enough vitamin d
and it has to do with
changes in our atmosphere it has to do
with the fact that we're indoors most of
the time that when we're outdoors we
usually wear clothes
i did run some experiments on myself or
i'm in hawaii for six weeks and i'm
pretty much in the sun as much as i can
probably in fact i know i got
some skin damage from that much sun and
i tested my vitamin d level since
you they were they were still low yeah
and it's because we have this high
variance in vitamin d receptor genes so
for me i need to take 15 000 ius a day
or i simply do not have adequate vitamin
d because i i basically have like a
pacific islanders vitamin d receptors
and a white boy's
skin so that combination is not good so
you have to do your d in magnesium
like everyone is magnesium deficient
we're just not getting enough of that so
if you were to do just magnesium d
and k2
many people now are taking vitamin d
because they've heard vitamin d
seems to lower your risk of dying from
all viral diseases including the famous
ones which we shall not name here
the ones that rhyme with chocolate cake
which is the new hashtag for it
and
well
if you take vitamin d
and you don't take vitamin k2 vitamin d
drives calcium into tissues that's good
unless it drives calcium into your penis
or into your
arteries
you don't want calcium in your scars so
what keeps calcium
where it belongs it's vitamin k2
not k1 from kale that doesn't work it's
k2 so take your d take your k2 take your
magnesium and you're going to live
longer and you're going to function
better now and those are just everyone
has to do it fortunately d and magnesium
are dirt cheap and k is moderately
expensive but not crazy
okay that's interesting my vitamin d is
always low and i've tried like
everything i was taking ten thousand ius
a day
uh that didn't seem to work either then
i tried intramuscular shots which i was
told are a good idea or a bad idea
depending on who you talk to that
actually bumped it up was the only thing
i've ever done that bumped it up
um i'm fairly tanned now so maybe it's
okay right now but also maybe not i
don't know
but
tanning is different than your d levels
so i i'm relatively tan as well but my d
levels if i didn't supplement wouldn't
be there
also and this is important for everyone
listening
even if you're taking your vitamin d
you have to turn it on and what turns on
vitamin d is sunlight so you you've got
to get sunlight in the eyes without
sunglasses and on the skin even if it's
just for 10 or 15 or 20 minutes a day
what ultraviolet light does to vitamin d
is it
sulfates it it makes vitamin d sulfate
which is what you really need so you
take the supplements and then you turn
it on
and if you're like i am up in canada in
winter it's tough in mid one you're not
going to get much of that stuff and
there's nothing wrong with using a
little bit of a safe tanning bed and
there is such a thing as a safe tanning
bed
okay
cool
well
i guess the last question
that people should know about are if
people have to just cut out a few foods
to make them feel better what are your
top evil foods
i am going to answer this in a way that
you probably don't expect it's from the
end of my fasting book
the hardest fast of all
is called fasting from hate
okay fair literally it's going for four
hours without thinking bad things about
any person anything about yourself or
even any food so literally four hours we
just don't think bad stuff about people
it's the hardest fast
right and it's part of the spiritual
fasting discipline which is different
than high performance work fasting
and so instead of answering the question
of what are the foods you should avoid
honestly
taking that that time to just turn down
the responsiveness and the anger and the
stress and if you look at the news
you're going to absolutely immediately
have negative thoughts you know oh i
just broke my fast damn what's going on
here so i'm gonna also
ask people watching this to think about
that with food so you can look at you
know a kale and spinach salad with tofu
nuggets on top and you can sort of throw
up in your mouth the way a sane person
would
but when you
when you get it
dialed in all the way you can actually
realize there's no reason or need to
feel revulsion to that you can just look
at that and say it's not food so we look
at a
bowl of rocks we don't feel revulsion of
that we just know it's not food
and you're going to get to the point
where you drive past a fast food place
you don't see it anymore because it's
not food
right and you're going to look at stuff
that's not food even if other people are
eating it and you might feel compassion
for the people eating it because it's
like they're punching themselves in the
face and they haven't figured it out yet
but you won't be angry and you won't be
upset you'll just be like you know what
maybe they'll see that my skin is better
and i'm healthier and have more energy
maybe they'll ask me someday why but in
the meantime i'm just going to shut up
and eat
so if you want to know what to eat
rather than what not to eat i could
answer that easily and what to eat is
anything that ate grass is probably
going to be good for you
and
anything that is a plant is much less
likely to be good for you so if you were
to take a plate and if you want
vegetables which i'm not opposed to at
all
lettuce is a relatively safe one uh
surprisingly
so look at some lettuce most people
tolerate avocados pretty darn well that
works nicely
most people tolerate olives but
not everyone and you don't want tons of
olives because they have some omega-6s
but you can eat things like that
and make sure that you have grass-fed
butter grass-fed meat and some fish but
probably not too much and if you did
that as the primary things you eat and
you never ate fried stuff
and you said grains and beans just
aren't food for me
you would probably love your life and
love your gut and you'd wake up without
sore joints
your back wouldn't hurt you your skin
would glow you wouldn't have pimples
and more importantly your emotional
control over yourself goes through the
roof and i think michaela you know what
i'm talking about when you're tired and
foggy like that because you ate the
wrong stuff you yell at people you love
and when you have enough energy to
regulate your emotions you're actually
kind and that's why this matters so much
yeah i completely agree a lot more
patience right you don't get that spike
of adrenaline everything something every
time something slightly annoying happens
exactly right so i'm a lot nicer when i
want to eat the right way but my
resilience now even if i eat the wrong
way i have more control than i did 10 or
20 years ago
but
some of that comes from personal
development but i will tell you if you
take the most enlightened guru on the
planet and you feed them garbage for two
years they're not going to be as
enlightened so food in our environment
is a part of what makes us nice to each
other and and that's so important to
recognize
okay thank you dave that was very
interesting uh if people
want to find you online where they where
should they go
well uh go to daveasprey.com is where
there's 3 000 blog posts several
challenges that are free moldy movie if
you care about toxic mold it's a gift
moldymovie.com
and bulletproof radio is pretty well
known as a podcast i'd love to see you
guys on there
thank you very much
[Music]
you